that's that's my question like why is he
so qualified to see this what do you
think he's not saying anything different
yeah now I kind of wish he's like he's
like they don't just have taco Tuesdays
down there they have taco Wednesdays and
Thursdays
[Music]
anybody know who this guy is
nope he looks like a veteran though like
every single time you see a picture of a
guy talking about war
he's a ufologist
oh yeah yeah it's he looks like the
perfect combination of both really he's
like an Air Force guy [ __ ] whistle
boy Scott is allegedly if you told me
he's on the Supreme Court I'd be like
all right a former I don't see him in a
rope that got his butt probed by aliens
oh that's a stereotype they don't do
that almost almost he's the guy at the
end of hook who finds his marbles
that guy
so this
guy's claiming
to be a former CIA agent and because he
is now months away from Death he's
finally at a place where he's like I'm
down to just spill more beans yeah oh
wait does he have kids because if you
don't have kids that I would believe it
why because if you do there's a
collateral to like they'll [ __ ] with you
because the government will kill your
kids like Rambo Rambo director I mean
rainbow never had one kid never had one
kid well is Rambo CIA
or he's like Green Beret he might as
well have been they will kill your kids
though I can't tell you
when Bart just cut deep
[Laughter]
but what if you're okay with that
with with them killing your kids I'm
just spilling the beans and by his age
his kids are like old that's a little
life hacker or what if he doesn't even
remember the Beatles the right way oh
yeah oh yeah you're so old you don't
remember those beans yeah the details
what have you just made made it up
because you know some people when they
die they just want to make up [ __ ] to be
a legend that's kind of that's kind of
tight like the guy who says he killed um
Tupac no oh Tupac there's a guy that
said that recently yeah really he like
comes he's like I killed Tupac I swear
to God he was like on his deathbed was
it in a rap song
did you guys see Tim Kennedy's post like
not too long ago he had every single
flight stud that he's ever taken
uh during his career in the military
because he doesn't know if they he ever
is going to need receipts in case some
[ __ ] ever happens wow to corroborate any
story or anything dude Tim Kennedy is
kind of Hardcore so like that's [ __ ]
crazy I would have crumpled it up and
thrown it away even the agency or
organization that hired you could turn
could turn their backs on you if you're
involved in deep enough which is what
happens to James Bond in every movie and
Jason Bourne and just kidding news you
see that's true anything that starts
with the J you don't know when your pay
is getting cut but it's getting good
okay we cut our own that's true that's
true we cut our own a year before you
guys did or you guys should have said
that from the beginning okay that's
literally what we said dude
you guys gotta clap back sooner okay you
said that right you should have told us
way before the meeting let's take it
back to the YouTube
we had no idea dude we're mad yeah bro
we you feel like to honestly right boys
we feel like you guys didn't tell us
earlier and now I feel bad don't flip
this on us I can't wait for people who
take things very literally yeah oh my
God JK is coming wow did you see them
getting that argument today holy [ __ ]
it's really over this time Joe and Bart
hating everybody just for the sake of
everybody to look mad for a second
Horrible Bosses yeah dude this one looks
happy as [ __ ] everybody looks mad he's
like Horrible Bosses
all right so back to Asian Cooper over
here this is a 77 year old dude who said
he worked for the agency between 1957
and 1960. uh he allegedly used a fake
name at the time which seems weird uh in
1998 he sat down with a journalist to
discuss his career and everything he
witnessed during that time however
um following the lengthy interview this
guy agent Cooper he called himself was
allegedly warned by the CIA to stop
talking about it this is back in 98. but
then they all died the ones that warned
him probably he probably outlived them
yeah dude 15 years later though with his
health decline declining he decides to
finally speak out again and this uh
recently came out uh or this time the
UFO researcher uh Richard Dolan put
together this documentary actually back
in 2014 called the anonymous interview
that put this guy in it so this is how
his information got out that's good [ __ ]
I hope he's not just like there's a
sacred elevator great
yeah yeah I don't care about secret
passageways and [ __ ] no one cares that
they get their paper towels from
Kirkland yeah the whole Area 51 Kirkland
yeah I mean there's a secret cafeteria I
can confirm
I have chili every Tuesdays so so he
says this is kind of stereotypical stuff
in the way I I read this but um
he he said he was once taken to Area 51
to analyze items found by the US
government among which was a spaceship
that had allegedly crashed and landed in
July 1947 in Roswell
does the CIA like look at alien
spacecraft though like what is this
qualification
after you've been there three years
Central Intelligence Agency right it's
intelligence it is intelligence okay
they gotta be centrally intelligent it's
an agency right so that's called
deductive reasoning and logic it's a
name I feel better about it the
firefighters really fight fires
it took us 13 or 15 miles south to S4
and like different garage door openings
okay and in these garage door openings
they had like different saucer crafts
the very first one had Roswell craft and
it was kind of crashed up but apparently
every alien I don't believe I don't
believe that it sounds freestyle kind a
crashed up I killed Tupac
um but apparently every alien that was
in it had died except for a couple the
Roswell craft was really strange because
it looked like a really heavy aluminum
foil we could walk next to it and the
whole thing probably weighed 150 to 300
pounds
he went on he said at S4 we viewed the
autopsy film and then the colonel said
that we've got in here is we're
interviewing a gray alien I thought we
had no idea we were going to see the
real thing all we saw was the film what
did this great alien look like could you
describe them a little bit he was asked
it didn't look human as far as the skin
tone and basically the shape of it and
the size how it was how its head size
compared with the normal human for
example the brain was kind of a little
bit bigger and the nose was very very
small and the ears were just like holes
and the mouth was very small
so do you think that they show this film
to ldci guys and then the guy is like
so uh
what do you guys think
that's what it's yeah it sounds like
it's [ __ ] crazy like how is this a
neat to know he's not saying why he was
shown that yeah what's what's it for I
thought the CIA was all about need to
know yeah like or is it like you don't
see like a Believer Ryan can you guys
believe this I mean he just sounds like
he just collected all the pop culture
alien [ __ ] over the like past 40 years
and just combined what else what else
dude they're [ __ ] allergic to water
do you guys swing a bat on a pitcher to
like what was he researching that's
that's my question like why is he so
qualified to see this what do you think
he's not saying anything different yeah
I could have made that up now I kind of
wish he's like he's like they don't just
have taco Tuesdays down there they have
taco Wednesdays and Thursdays yeah it's
tacos every day you can get him anytime
they're lying to you
right dude this is just Bob's our story
recycled this is like a Greatest Hits
and or do you think they're all the same
people that actually are whistleblowing
the same event I mean and it's actually
absolutely true because you would have
different sources yeah like confirm
what's the purpose of the event because
the show [ __ ] VHS y'all check this
out yeah it would have been sick if you
came out while all that stuff was like
coming out yeah and then confirming
because what you said you mentioned Bob
Lazar story and he said it sounds just
like that well yeah Bob's are who is why
our lexicon has S4 in it because he's
the one who said that they had a place
called S4 do we know that that's real
well this guy's saying he was at S4 so
like but Bob bizarre handed that to our
lexicon you've seen that [ __ ] right yeah
so maybe this is why we should be
involved in pop culture because this guy
didn't even know who Bob Lazar was and
then out of nowhere he's like I'm gonna
finally do it and then people are like
[ __ ] Bob was already [ __ ]
told us and he thought oh I was waiting
all this time someone else peeled the
bee but somebody needs to check his
internet history because I bet he has a
bunch of Bob Lazar stories yeah he's
just [ __ ] biting his [ __ ] pink links
yeah yeah yeah
why are them links pink whoa dude did
you click on these licks
they should be blue is it really like do
you really believe that he only worked
at the CIA three years and he already
had top level clearance see the store is
my address dude I know you have to at
least do internships
and they let you see that [ __ ] in three
years Bob Lazar uh claims he was hired
in the late 1980s to reverse engineer
extraterrestrial uh technology and was
born in 1959 this guy said he was
working in the CIA from 1957. it was way
early on yeah and looking at the Roswell
crashing 47 yeah which is what bubbazar
says he says that they told him it was
the Roswell or it was linked to that or
I don't [ __ ] like 37 years later yeah
[ __ ] sounds too easy you can't even see
the top floor of the Scientology
building until you've been there for
like a decade like this is two years
she's not going clear dude it is clear
it is crazy that we all know the like
super secret of Scientology which is
like the zenu [ __ ] which is like [ __ ]
wild [ __ ] and they don't know the
workers don't I mean the ones that in
the church don't I think they have to
live action role play they don't know
what's the Zeno [ __ ] like the
live-action role play yeah because
everyone knows now that they did the
going clear thing like it's like okay
when you get to the highest highest
level they're like all right so the real
secret of the universe is like so
there's like a talking volcano and uh
yeah and a bunch of spirits alien
Spirits go inside of it like yeah they
all go to some alien planet or something
they go in the volcano and the volcano
explodes them and then all these Spirits
go out to the rest of the world and then
that becomes the different races or some
[ __ ] yeah it's like some L Ron Hubbard
[ __ ] why are you saying it like it's
weird no it's not it's just um why are
you saying like you don't believe it no
I do believe it just like xenu's the God
lord zinu yeah Xena Warrior Princess or
your prince
there it is should have seen the master
and Gabriella so we're not what else did
this guy says what else do you saying is
that it that's all he has that's
basically all he has they were great
they had big eyes they had no ears like
all right bro dude I'd be leaving this
press conference early
first one and said welcome to Earth
[Music]